[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
comment sont-ils et regardez moi ça
commence et joli ces on n'est pas sorti
de l'auberge
et aujourd'hui on est chez mongie et
martin ils vont nous présenter du café
et où le café pas n'importe quel café
marmaille le pointu de bois bon le top
du top
celui dont la folle tous les amateurs de
café parce que là c'est la réunion et on
y va tout de suite parce qu'on n'est pas
dans l'est pas sorti de l'auberge parce
que c'est comme ça parce que je suis moi
et moi j'ai pu tout à fait déjà je parle
qu'on vite je fais c'est aller pour bien
commencer ma petite journée et me
réveillez moi j'ai pris un café arabica
noir et bien corsé jo film a pas qu'à ça
y est je vais y aller
ou est ce que tu vas me crie mon nez
mais revenons à kawa je viens de me
lever et en avance bonjour martin
bonjour comment il est allé là mais là
mais là les la voile a dit elle est là
les trois ans qu'il est là une boîte du
bon café ça se voit tout de suite
bah ouais mais aussi d'accueil à nous
déjà saisi vraiment et ben voilà la noix
arrive nous aurons tout de suite dans le
vif du sujet alors explique comment un
petit peu où nous les et qu'est ce que
tu fais s'il te plaît alors ça nous
laisse donc la nuée sur bois de nèfles
saint paul dans les eaux dans les eaux
néo 1000 mètres d'altitude la donc
exploitations agricoles en bio
totalement en bio donc là là dessus nous
fait du café un hectare cinq cafés
après évidemment d'un petit élevage de
poules pondeuses n'a pas mal d'agrumes
nous fait un petit peu de maraîchage
donc voilà pas mal pas mal de fruitiers
et médicinales et tout ça à mélanger
tout ça dans un petit fou y
bien rigolo et tout ça en bio évidemment
pour respecte nature et pour les
spectateurs
moi je crois que ça commence bien on dit
bio on dit pour médicinales il dit petit
maraîcher et dissuade tout pointu de
beaubois il m'avait pas que ça y'en a
déjà commencé la récolte la scène du
café et cette année donc il ya mater
finir hamas et donc nous l'avait m a
fait amender le café fait à monter en
fait ip ip à mes deux que le café d'un
milieu goût à la tasse de thé donc là il
va fé amant 12 24 heures à peu près donc
l'ami mettre de l'eau et pim il a avalé
n 2 fois et après mais ça va au séchage
qu'on laisse aller comme ça la saison de
l'eau en fait c'est dans de l'eau vient
il à sa liseuse dans de l'eau et comme
le carton expliquerait donc en fait
c'est juste sucré gembloux va faire
monter cette fermentation donc voilà bah
donne un bon but 1 milieu brocante et à
la tâche mon ami du plaza
comment donner les glaces et bah oui on
en a combien de plans pour demain la
fête
de la récole donc ce qui veut dire qu'en
ce moment il peut avoir jusqu'à 4 5
grains par à pied n'ont pour l'instant
du coup pour l'instant nous obligés de
passer un petit peu sur toutes les
parcelles pour avoir un petit peu cette
quantité l'a donc à peu près suis allé
un hectare mais quand va bien commencer
la récolte
cette quantité là nous peut ramasser sûr
on va dire une cinquantaine de pieds à
peu près donc là maintenant au mot café
les rincer à béthanie asséché
[Musique]
que nous nous répète pas assez souvent
mais le pointu de bois bon il faut dire
que c'est fait partie d'un des meilleurs
cafés au monde à lundi au monde
c'est le deuxième meilleur deuxième
donc classe café comme sa maman donc
ceci bois alu la réunion aux hôteliers
paye ali nous allons te trois mots trois
ou cinq ans peut-être jusqu'à 4 ans et
atteint sous la part actions en france
en suisse en belgique ou en asie on peut
pas y aller entre 9 et 20 euros la tasse
nous à la vie
[Musique]
le trio
on est toujours là
donc là on a le quartier devienne est là
on en as tu du café 9 ans et chez g
combien de temps que ça d ici l a été
mis à sécher depuis quatre jours là il
faut compter encore au moins plus de 10
jours polypes lié bien et dont l'âme
suppose que déclare la moindre petite
farine ou n'importe quoi ça quant à la
moindre petite farine aller ou
faiblesses nos affaires en data lié au
moins comme ça
le affaire qui n'est pas la plus soit sa
zone technique macgyver en italie mais
disons que en regardant les autres faire
en prenant les idées dit c'est nous je
saisis et invendus le café le café
rencontre la cce doit inventer la
variété de cafés
[Rires]
[Musique]
là dessus les cartes et la nok en coop
comme si la petite côte d'ivoire ça y
appelle une part hockey et donc après on
a ça on a ce petit grain de café la
caisse à oissel café vers le café chez
nous tant qu'allié nous comme ça avec sa
part ch
d'accord nous met dans des boîtes
hermétiques nos stocks à 10 ans passe
comme ça et ensuite quand nous ne la des
commandes seulement comme on a des
commandes l'avionneur nova départ chez
ba qu il nous va torréfié tout de suite
donc c'est vraiment du café frais à
chaque fois que mes livres moment
clients toujours par souci d 2 2 je m'en
soucie de goût de qualité de ketchup aux
ottomans mayotte la halle elle travaille
là elle prend des techniques aux hot
pour le boulet mieux on trouve ça
fantastique
[Musique]
alors marine leurs descendants le la
plantation de café c'est ça donc là on
voit les pieds les bien chargé il a pas
mal de grain bon pas mal de vienne
encore vert parce que comme l'a expliqué
tout à l'heure nous commence à peine la
récolte d'un cône a pas mal pas mal de
cerises vers dessus donc là on va aller
voir mon mari est bon que les en train
de cueillir sa té rouge vous cache pas
où on travaille pas alors non mais qui
sait cause exacte si moi me travaille
pas non mais c'est pas moi c'est autre
chose
voilà cela voulait un mix-prix case up
c'est que le café philo matches
entendent recueillies avec l'ifo calcul
kremlin
[Musique]
à notre joie ni à la donc là le gars y
enlève rien que ça te les rouges du
rouge du rouge bordeaux faut vraiment
que ce soit bien rouge partout donc
c'est vraiment une cueillette sélective
combien d'années ces arbres le taux de
non la main
cela ne l'a dû planter vers 2002 2003
par là encore c'est déjà un joli conte
on a oui c'est déjà d'évoquer
[Musique]
c'est quoi la saison sinon même saison
mais suppose que dans une saison oui les
naines saison mi juin et nous fini
seulement mois décembre janvier qu'en
fait comme vous l'a vu talent est là
n'avaient pas mal de cerises verte
encore pas mal de petites graines encore
lille commence à grossir
donc là ne commence à ramasser et nous
va revenir tout le temps comme ça seul
et même rap dans le déni cerise rouge
quand même là des cerises ronchamp click
& figures hauke mais non il fait deux
ans trois ans maintenant que ne commence
à que mois de juin alors qu'avant 3,80
en arrière nous taire ramasse le café à
partir du mois de septembre
d'accord que au mois de septembre et
nous définit au mois de janvier février
alors que maintenant nous commençons
déjà au mois de juin
est-ce que c'est dit
sûrement climatique the war non mais
c'est comment à part ça qu après midi
[Musique]
autre local bio et j'ai fait ça avec
amour vous mais c'est à dire oui je
serai content la cueillette l'infini une
anode joli grain bien rouge bien ramassé
d'accord nous met ali dans la machine et
alain qui est la machinerie appels entre
pulpeuse facile pour enlever la peau du
café
un exploit un petit peu cette pièce là
parce que mais c'est une pièce très très
important oui donc là on est dans la
pièce son taux refi on stocke aussi un
peu le café un donc 20 25 minutes à 180°
le café la fi nit horrifié ensuite il
donne à nous ce qu'a fait la manif est
sentie house a fait un le trésor de la
réunion long de l'année sans bon plus
voilà on déjoue lions diamanti peu
comment la rivale à ste plaît tous
étaient ravis
donc moi et mon mari ne l'est pas du
tout du de l'agriculture d'avant en fait
notre travail dans le bâtiment
rien à voir deux rien à voir donc en
fait le terrain c'est un terrain mon
papa tu exploite un terrain de cet effet
géraniums que notre terrain dans les
hauts de saint-paul des géraniums dessus
ne la récupère le terrain et puis voilà
et puis on a commencé à travailler comme
ça notre but c'était vraiment de
travailler proprement enfin que
proprement ne pas utiliser d'engrais
chimiques de travailler avec cette
menace l'exploitation ne tue imier boeuf
notre fumier volailles etc
du coup nous dit bon bah pourquoi pas
essayer le café et là nous la tombe
amoureux de cette plante de ceux des
produits et cetera donc ne la forme à
nous aussi de dans la forme à monsieur
la plantation mais nous la forme année
aussi sur la dégustation sur la
torréfaction et c'est ce que the tea
expo où est ce que les seulement pour de
la production locale
alors nous évidemment nous vend une
grosse partie ici parce que ici bas me
fais des visites guidées sur le café
pour des touristes et cino une grosse
partie de mon café depuis à peu près
trois ans maintenant ils savent à
l'étranger telles que l'asie mais aussi
un des pays européens suisses belges
on y trouve ça fantastique et d'ailleurs
il faut une fois que je peux il faut
exporter qu'on a des bons produits donc
pour l'effrontée martin mais aussi
d'autres accueillent ici
merci à tous et bonne continuation
mais c'est azote
beaucoup de courage et bravo poser
d'exploitation merci moi je m'en vais à
plus tard
[Musique]
donc on a visité un petit peu toute
l'exploitation avec le café de mahassine
produit local bio donc bien sûr
consommer local il faut aider nos
maraîchers de nos planteurs parce que
maintenant et travaille dur peu donne un
autre bon produit 1 donc faut pas
hésiter je vous dis tout simplement
aurevoir à la prochaine patati patata et
on n'est pas du tout sorti de l'auberge
c'est vrai parce que quand on rentre
dans l'auberge c'est tellement bien en
fait qu'on veut pas sortir enfin de
comprendre cela et à un moment donné tu
rentres dans l'auberge comme ça et puis
tu peux plus sortir
tu me plaît parce que c'est tellement
bien il ya du bon café il ya des bonnes
tomates
[Musique]